i'll ask this question what do earl
campbell jim taylor larry zonka terrell
davis and leroy kelly all have in common
they're all running backs they're all
hall of fame running backs and they all
are looking up at our next guest on the
all-time russian list who is 26th
all-time in the nfl russian list with 10
591 yards and now an acting career that
just keeps on building and building and
building
johnson airs sundays at 8 pm eastern on
bounce encores the next day streaming on
brown sugar one of the co-leads and
co-executive producers of this show is
thomas q jones back here on the program
how you doing thomas
rich i'm doing great thank you for
having me always a pleasure to be on
your show brother always a pleasure to
be uh uh with you in your company um so
uh before you get to your show and
acting and things of that nature
what do you make of uh what the bears
are doing with justin fields and how
the bears fans might be receiving uh the
news that their first round quarterback
is the only one who might not be
starting or having any role in week
number one of the season
well i definitely think the bears are
ready for uh justin fields and they're
ready for his talents i think he had a
really good preseason
uh obviously it still is the preseason
it's it's a different speed and
different energy in the regular season
but um
i can understand their frustration
you know they drafted him number one you
want to see the guy play you know he's
excited them in the preseason and
they won't see that during week one
because i mean you've had a front row
seat for that sort of pressure and
frustration
uh even when
you went to the super bowl you know so
you
that's that's part of
you know that's part of the history of
what's led up to this moment
that's kind of putting a lid on top of
that boiling pot that you know
andy dalton could turn down the pressure
on that boiling pot with his play but um
i don't know is my simple
i guess set up to your answer
of whatever you think
well i mean andy's experience he's been
in the league for a long time it's it's
something this is regular season it's
week one everything counts now uh you
know everyone's playing everyone's
playing for uh you know
stats they're playing for
bonuses i mean you know
it's the real deal now and you know i
can understand why they want to put andy
in first you know give andy an
opportunity to to go out there and um
you know
uh
kind of see what that offensive line is
going to do you know see see you know
what their receivers are going to do
before they just throw justin out there
to the wolves
um so i can see it from both
perspectives but but i definitely
understand why the fans want to see him
out there immediately then you also had
a front row seat to another fan base
that's scarred one that includes me with
a quarterback
um
i can't believe i can't believe i'm
putting my eggs in yet another
new rookie quarterback basket but here
we are with the jets and
and zach wilson uh yeah you know i do
you have any thoughts on on that and
what you've seen out of him and
what you think of the jets going back to
this well one more time thomas yeah i
mean i i think the kid is talented he's
got a strong arm you know he seems to
have great instincts
um but you know like i said it is the
pre-season and i think justin fields
made a comment about you know the game
was i don't know if he said it was
slower or
what he said about the preseason but
um
when you get into regular season the
energy picks up
um and then when you go from the
the regular season to mid season it
picks up then from mid-season to
the end of the season where you're
fighting for a playoff spot it picks up
and now it's the playoffs and each game
it picks up
more and more until you get to super
bowl so i think with these kids you know
they're they're super talented
but it's a little bit different um for
for for rookies on you know
day one of the regular season so i'm
looking forward to seeing how they do i
mean it's very unpredictable you know
we've seen kids that come in with a lot
of talent that all of a sudden just
explode on you know day one and then
we've seen guys
uh like me for example i was a seventh
overall pick and my first game in new
york i had 12 carries for 16 yards that
was my first first game at the
meadowlands you know ever in the nfl is
12 for 16. i'm the seventh overall pick
stop in the air man we'll see what
happens
i got out right here you had four
catches for 18 yards too don't just sell
your shorts don't sell yourself short
time
yeah
i guess that added to my all-purpose
yards yeah but i'm looking at you you
didn't have a geez you didn't have a
100-yard game in your career until you
had week two of your third year you went
to seattle you lit it up
173 yards rushing
that day yeah it was it was uh those are
some tough times in arizona to be honest
um you know which which really you know
forced me to have to
you know decide what i wanted my career
to be you know am i gonna go out as
you know a first round you know
draft pick that didn't pan out
or am i gonna
uh you know have some sort of legacy in
this league you know so i wouldn't
change anything it was definitely tough
times but
um you know i wouldn't change anything
yeah no and i'm not bringing that up
just to say that but it's just the
conversation that you hear so many times
thomas q jones here on the rich eisen
show actor and former running back in
the nfl um that that that you're
you know
it's it's a it's a lottery how you get
drafted and where you go and the luck
that you have and a coach that you get
in the system that you get and the coach
and a front office that you get that's
going to actually keep something in
place and have a plan for you and put it
into
put it into place and you know that's
why you take a look at
quarterbacks and where they get drafted
and who they get and what a problem is i
mean sam donald is now in year four
for him or year five now for him
where he's now
in a new spot he's in year four and he
doesn't even know how good he can be i
mean stafford near now what 1213 he
doesn't even know it's kind of crazy
sometimes
how it works like that
it is because the nfl is not just about
talent
and i don't think
um a lot of fans really understand that
there has to be
a lot of other elements for you to be
able to maximize your potential and your
talents you know when i was in arizona
at that time
you know arizona was very
cheap
and um you know just to be be honest i
mean they they would go after
um
veteran players that they didn't have to
really pay as much and even though they
might be skilled and smart they're not
as athletic
as some of the younger players so in
arizona we always had a mixture of
older older veterans that were like
on their way out of the league and
young rookies like me who were
first-year second-year guys so there
were there were no middle tier players
that kind of could even have that out
um and so it was a very tough situation
because um although i had leadership
physically a lot of those guys just
couldn't perform especially on offense
and so it left me in a bind for a few
years
um and then i was able to go to tampa
where they had just won the super bowl
great front office they were spending
money they also had a nice mixture of
veterans and younger players and then i
was able to you know
uh adjust
and and see how a team should be run
from the players from the front office
and then the next year to chicago and
now i had all those experiences
to you know catapult me into my my you
know jump start my career in chicago but
it took all of those things
collectively to for me to put the click
for me
um and for me to be able to be in a
situation where i could be successful so
a lot of pressure on lottery picks but
it takes a lot for them to be successful
not just their talent how good is derek
henry man i mean uh he is he's currently
a hundred he's currently a hundredth on
the all-time rushing list with
5860 yards and now he's gonna get an
extra game
i mean
he could be like two or three seasons
from running you down it's just insane
what he's doing right and and certainly
in in this passing league let's spread
it out let's get fast guys you see
what's going on in miami everybody's got
like track speed
play a quick game make some sort of
problem for you know the the the safety
that's too big to cover somebody small
like that's this game today but now
there's some old school guys just going
to hit you in the mouth and you're just
going to think about it for five six
straight days in the defensive film room
until it's time to actually see him in
person
it's it's kind of a rarity i wonder what
you think thomas jones i i think you
throw back he reminds me of the backs
uh that were there and you know uh
and then the
you know 70s 80s
90s
you know mid-2000s my era you know until
the game shifted a little bit
uh into a little bit more of a passing
lead
um he reminds me of those guys he
definitely would have been right in the
mix with all those guys that i played
with in that era
he's tough he's big he knows how to uh
you know protect himself you know
um
and he's been doing it since high school
i saw a highlight the high school clip
of him
um where he ran for like 10 000 yards in
high school or
something i mean i was looking up
something i my junior and senior year in
high school my junior year i had i
rushed for 3 319 yards and my senior i
rushed for 2007 yards wow and uh and
someone sent me uh
someone sent me a list of the top 20
high school performances of all time
and i think derek henry
i had two two of those years and derrick
henry had two and one of them was like 4
000 or something yards
um and he's been doing this forever i
think he's the only person to go rush
for 2000
in college 2000 in the pros obviously
high school thousands
yeah high school something like i don't
know something but i don't know man the
guys
freaking nature love love to run and
watch him run man tough smart
got great body control
i mean pull away speed breakaway to get
that big who's who's the worst you ever
stiff-armed anybody thomas
yeah the worst stiff arm you gave to
somebody um i think the worst diploma i
ever gave someone was uh
we're playing the dolphins when i was in
new york
and uh
my first year 2007. there's actually a
clip of it on youtube okay um and i
actually stepped on one god three times
in the same on the same play i don't
know how that happened who was it but um
what's his name do you remember uh
travis i played with him in kansas city
too
um he played for the dolphins he played
corner okay um his name was travis um
i can't think of his last name i think
his last name his last name was
posterize i think it's travis poster
yeah that's it that's man i don't know
how i could think of that yeah that's
his next travis poster ride but i ended
up playing with him in kansas city and
his locker was right next to my
ironic i mean out of all the guys that i
could end up sitting next to in a locker
it was the same guy that i still farmed
in 2007 which was three years before
that three times on the same play
um travis daniels that's his name i love
travis that's my man
he had to eat thomas jones's palm for at
least three times in that game that's
amazing yeah man yeah i mean you know he
was in the way
that was probably that was probably one
of the uh
i guess the most vicious stiff arms uh
derek henry's stiff form is i mean
nasty this is a weapon yeah he might
start getting uh unsportsmanlike conduct
penalties this year just by getting off
the bus it might be considered on
sportsman like conor he's amazing yeah
yeah he's he's he's tossing grown men
around like
toys thomas thomas q jones here on the
rich eisen show all right let's talk
about johnson uh that airs sundays 8 p.m
eastern on bounce um what what did you
what do you like about this what do you
want people to know about it and
check it out with encores the next day
streaming on brown sugar what do you got
for me thomas q jones
yeah johnson is a show that uh i'm
executive producing the cedric the
entertainer and my producer partner
daisy lorraine who's the actual actual
uh creator of the show
and uh we we've been working on the show
for the last
four or five years
uh we were fortunate enough to to
have bounce tv pick it up
um and it's a show about four black men
living in atlanta and uh just some of
the
conflicts that we go through when our
friendships and our relationships and
um just in the world we live in you know
it's very honest show you know uh we
talk about some controversial topics but
uh the ratings have been incredible
actually the first
episode uh aired
and it broke the bounce tv record for uh
most viewership outstanding um
yeah for the an opening night so it was
over 2.1 million people and the views
have been incredible with feedback uh so
we're on episode seven is ten episodes
in the season
and uh yeah you can check it out we're
off this weekend because of labor day
we'll be back for episode seven next
sunday eight seventh century on bounce
tv
uh you can also download the app brown
sugar and you can see all of the uh the
episodes to get called up but what's it
like we're excited what's it like
working with dl
hugley oh yeah the ugly is incredible uh
earthquake they're hilarious i mean uh
udl plays my uncle on the show and
you know it's cool because you know he's
funny but you know he's playing a
serious character
you know um so we get into some heavy
conversation
and um it's like it's great work with
him he's i mean
super insightful professional
it's been an incredible experience
especially to be a you know executive
producer and a show runner uh daisy and
i we're the show runners so you know
pretty much everything goes through us
all the writing all the editing music
everything goes through us
and um it's been a great ride man i'm
really excited definitely you should
check it out man johnson on bounce tv 87
central sunday night how do you like
being management thomas how do you like
that
i love it i love it you know um i'm a
very hands-on person
well we just learned that i think travis
daniels learned that back in the day but
yeah yeah
yeah yeah unfortunately travis had to
learn that in the you know oh it's going
on camera right but um but no it's fun
you know
it's a lot of responsibility um the rush
of it is
uh is similar to what football felt like
you know it's high stakes all the time i
mean you're putting a tv show out there
people could like it or they could say
it sucks and either way you have to
you know uh deal with the the results of
that and so fortunately for us people
left the show
uh and
you know i know one thing about me is i
want to make sure that things are done
right and so uh so it's really good to
be in this position and also now you
know we have other projects through our
production company and uh wish that
we're shopping to network so people can
see that daisy and i show runners and
creators you know we can take
responsibility of a major budget and
turn into a successful tv show well
thomas q jones um thanks for calling in
as you know any of your projects that
you're doing you always have a place
here to uh to call in and chit-chat and
promote it always
rich i appreciate you man i love your
twitter feed bro thank you laughing man
you know you know in the uh in uh
you know in person you know i'm in miami
right now but uh definitely next time
man um i want to be uh in person there
with you guys man i love your energy and
there's so much fun well right back at
you um let's do it and you stay safe in
the meantime
okay thank you we do i appreciate it uh
on twitter thomas q jones i follow him
you should too same on instagram at
thomas q jones 10
591 yards
seventh overall pick in 2000. hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here